so Harlequin guys how are you guys doing
all right so this young man has accused
me of Mis calling him and I thought it's
fair enough for me to actually see what
he's talking about because
misrepresentation obviously is not fair
practice it's not from the Islamic
morals and he's claimed he's made a very
blunt claim that I've misrepresented him
and so therefore it needs to be checked
what is he talking about and thankfully
enough he's left it as you can see time
stamps because he's made a very long
video and just to remind you guys this
this debate that he's commentating on
took place a year ago okay so obviously
I've had to dig up very quickly heal my
phone using this app some of these
quotations so let's see what he has to
say oh sorry sorry let's go back or is
it he says misquoting me so let's see
might be anyway let's take a look at
Muhammad here jobs opening statement and
we'll break it down and see where things
went a bit wrong first day of Ramadan
for us and we're happy to have you come
here the lacs you've come in through a
few magic wait a minute what did you say
let me say that one more time we've come
into a few magic it's actually a an
interesting magic trick where there is
no bunny
there's no Hat and in fact there's no
magician at all
it's the proposition that something can
come from nothing not only from nothing
ladies and gentlemen but from nothing
and by nothing no it's hard to clearly
make out under the thunderous laughter
that resulted from Mohammed his
brilliant joke but I think what he's
saying is that an atheist in this debate
is making a claim that something came
from nothing which of course made that
claim that someone said that I just made
the point that this is a proposition so
I haven't said anyone said that so just
just be clear of what you're trying to
communicate so far there's not
there's nothing there's no misquotation
yeah it's not the case I was countering
their claim rather than making a claim
of my own but that's something that will
come up in the later section Francis I
in immoral holophone I'm colorful
silhouettes you allowed balor opinion
what they created from nothing or were
they themselves the creators of
themselves now we've heard Alex today
for the second time I've heard him say
this he says that the universe may have
come into existence from nothing
we're at four so I said for the we've
heard Alex today yeah today yes and then
which is what he's taking issue with you
in this particular quotation I then
quote a thing that Alex says and with a
timestamp so let's see what I quote and
see what if he actually said oh no team
2:15 in his video does universe have a
cause it says well the universe came
into existence it well and truly came
into existence from nothing now wait a
minute
ladies and gentlemen I have a challenge
that's an active claim he said I'm not
here to make any active claims sorry
that is an active claim oh ho muhammed
hijab you have just in Barrett look I
mean you're getting a bit overexcited
here but before you get overexcited can
you tell me what's the excitement all
about yourself beyond measure I'm about
to demonstrate to you by just by showing
the clip that you just cited that you
are either completely deaf or completely
dishonest I don't know which it is but I
cannot believe you actually just said
that your to me right anyways let's see
what you have to say absolutely going to
love this well you might hate it but you
know what I mean let's just listen again
to the claim that Muhammad his job is
making make sure you understand it
before I show before a show let's be
civil about this go ahead and show a
clip going wrong here minute 14 to 15 in
his video does universe have a cause
it says when the universe came into
existence it well and truly came into
existence from nothing okay so in my
video I say that when the universe began
to exist it began to exist out of
nothing but that's a claim the universe
began to exist out of nothing that's a
claim and active claim I'm making that I
have to defend now Muhammad kind of
presses the point just a little bit that
this is a claim that I'm gonna have to
prove and defend let's let's take a
listen to that - ladies and gentlemen I
have a challenge that's an active claim
he said I'm not here to make any active
claims sorry that is an active claim
look at the syntax of that particular
sentence you're saying the universe came
into existence from nothing don't don't
pretend to be passive oh I don't know
you do know you're making a statement
either you know what you're saying when
you don't tell me how the universe came
into existence from nothing and by
nothing exnihilo I want to know tell me
how that's possible metaphysically
ontological cosmologically from first
principles give me the answer please
okay I'm beginning to get the impression
that Muhammad hijab wants me to justify
my claim that the universe began to
exist out of nothing okay
slight problem with that I never said
that
Muhammad hijab has quoted me quoting
someone else's belief there's two things
I said this is the second time we've
heard it today the first time was in
your opening statement he says there's a
matter in the universe
the fact of the matter is we have no
experience with nothing and so to say
something can't come from nothing is not
justifiable claim nothing is an
unjustifiable claim which means to say
that it's conceivable in his mind that
something can come from nothing and I
just find this very odd I find it so
weird that he's he's saying he's he's
claiming I'm misrepresenting his claim
this is clear he's saying he's
practically saying it's conceivable that
something that can come from nothing
tell me how does a passive claim please
tell me as a passive claim tell me how
that's not active tell me how that's not
you making a statement of knowledge come
on man stop whining and so complain just
you can change your mind you can say you
know what the argument was strong enough
for me to change my mind on the issue
but please don't pretend yeah that you
were not saying this from the beginning
please don't pretend
don't act don't pretend that you were
actually saying it's conceivable that
the universe or something can come from
nothing in this in this College listen
to next we've never had any nothing to
try it with in fact the only time there
was nothing if there was nothing ever at
all must happen before the universe was
created he says the only time there was
nothing if there was nothing at all was
with the universe was created since
other languages using using the word
create it wow that's religious language
damn boy creates it did no creator
created by whom by by what but you know
how is it created Oh possibly by nothing
so you see that is your that is your
claim you're making it very clear for us
you said on the day not be
misrepresented see and this is the only
way yeah yo yo yo you're trying to
weasel out of it trying to squirm your
way yeah out of the reality he's
misrepresenting misquoted me this and
that bro he said on the day you said on
the day yeah I don't pretend that you
know this was not your position your
position was that clearly it was
conceivable for you that something can
come from nothing so the question of the
Quran I'm holy woman holy shape where
they created from nothing you're saying
possibly yeah shrugging your shoulders
and now you realize how embarrassing you
are to to to go against the Quranic
argument it's a chronic argument you
know how embarrassing it wants to go
against it so but let's see this
particular timestamp reference which
you're gonna give us now watching me
quoting a belief that I don't agree with
and is claiming that I was making that
claim okay
I'm gonna prove this to you by simply
finding the quote that he provided and
demonstrating to you what happened here
so let's just find the quote minute 14
to 15 in his video does universe have a
cause it says what the universe came
into existence it won't truly came into
existence from nothing okay here we also
let me just play this now and firstly of
course we have the universe when the
universe came into existence it truly
did come into existence out of nothing
okay because for the universe to be born
if there was something before it then
that would be encompassed by the
universe so this dear truly begin to
exist
nothing ah interesting seems like I said
it when the universe began to exist it
truly came into existence out of nothing
Wow Muhammad hijab has really owned me
there except no he hasn't because let's
just go a few minutes earlier in this
very same video because any follower of
my channel will know that I don't make
that claim I don't say that the universe
began to exist out of nothing so why did
I say it there well let's go back and
find out in this talk that I'm giving
I'm talking about the Kalam cosmological
argument which is an argument with two
premises the first premise is that
everything which begins to exist has a
cause the second premise is that the
universe began listen first of all
there's no I've written a book called
Kalam cosmological arguments this is a
mistake many people like yourself make
it's there's not one Kalam cosmological
argument there are many Kalam
cosmological arguments the motor
kalamoon were Muslim
you know theologians you can say system
axial audience and they worked on first
principles and Allah has early this is a
Holly he wrote this in his book called a
leftist artfully are too hot obviously
it was popularized by William Lane Craig
but this is only one of his arguments
that he mentioned in that book which is
not even translated into English so you
must have gotten it from William Lane
Craig because he's the one who
popularized it or someone like him from
the philosophers of religion
so it's not one Kalam cosmological
argument as many Muhammad all has early
mentions this one in Lukis thoughtfully
utter fraud but he also mentions many
other ones actually in to have the earth
if he have the Philosopher's the
incoherent sort of philosophers so
please don't make it as if you were
educating anyone you're still an
undergraduate you know you're still
learning okay with all due respect this
and you don't even have access to the
these books in the original language so
have some intellectual humility
there's not one Kalam cosmological
argument you can refer to my book is
called Kalam cosmological arguments I
can give it to you free of charge if you
want just so you can see what I'm
talking about and
exist in the conclusion that the
universe has a cause notice that the
second premise there that the universe
began to exist that's the second premise
of the Kalam that's the claim that
Muhammad hijab says I made and have to
defend so let's take a look at what I
actually say about these premises the
premises I didn't say anything like that
you're lying because what I just said
what you've shown us is that I said that
you said that the universe may have come
from nothing I don't say anything about
that you said the Kalam cosmological
argument second premise that you had
that you've said that and you have to
defend that see now you're
misrepresenting me unless you can find
somewhere where I've said you have to
defend the second premise of the Kalam
cosmological argument suddenly you're
not very accurate with what you're
saying most people when they see this
and they're trying to debunk it they
jump straight to the second premise this
seems the easiest debunked the reason
being and is you can simply ask well how
do you know how do you know that the
universe began to exist now to be sure
the Big Bang happened
okay we're pretty certain of it at this
point but the Big Bang never claimed to
be the beginning of everything okay so
here's our first indication that
something's gone wrong I'm arguing that
actually that premise that the universe
began to exist can't be substantiated
even if we agree that the Big Bang
happened you can't say that that was the
beginning of everything the beginning of
the universe with the capital you okay
so maybe I'm not making that claim but
why did I say it later in the video then
why did I say it such that Mohamed hijab
could quote it well let's continue what
we could do is say all you can't prove
that this is the case so the arguments
thought is debunked and we can all go
home
but that would be no fun and so I don't
want to focus on premise two we're going
to give the theist the the benefit of
the doubt here and instead talk about
premise one whatever begins to exist has
a cause we're going to give the theist
the benefit of the doubt in other words
I think that this premise that the
universe began to exist isn't true but
I'm willing to grant it for the sake of
argument really because that's not what
I was going there was a nice try but
this is what I was referencing right
here
and the reason is because there's an
even more glaring issue that's staring
us right in the face that I ignored for
so long until somebody showed it to me
and I thought my god he's talking about
himself he's not quoting anybody else
how didn't I think of that before and I
said my god because old habits die hard
which means this it's an intuitive thing
to believe in God just like you believe
in that you get scared of Hell sometimes
what you've said in a video of yours I
can get you the call the problem is in
the first premise again whatever begins
to exist has a cause now people don't
spend enough time just thinking about
what this implies when have you ever
seen anything begin to exist
well I made a little list examples of
things that have been created out of
nothing that's what that means and
firstly of course we have the universe
when the universe you just said now if
you said I made a little list you said I
I didn't say this person or that person
no no you said I you said I made the
little list examples of things that were
created out of nothing and then you put
the first thing the universe so it's
clear your position is that the universe
was created out of nothing and you did
say that and this was a fair reference
and if you look at the time stamp
it's minute fourteen point two four so
it's what was wrong with what I said
into existence it truly did come into
existence out of nothing okay you're
saying that when the universe came into
existence it truly did come into
existence out of nothing this is not me
quoting you quote someone else this is
clearly you saying this yourself you are
saying that the universe came into
existence out of nothing you have said
that and you cannot you realize how
ridiculous is so you're trying your best
to weasel your way
of this but this is what you said you're
saying I misquoted you but this is not
misquotation
unfortunately yeah this is not
so this is the reality of the situation
there where's your was your finger
exposed yeah I don't think there's much
explosion going on it I think you're
kind of to be honest with all due
respect you're kind of embarrassing
yourself here but let's see it says
misquoting me yeah you see that we dealt
with that now so clearly it wasn't a
misquotation it clearly it was in its
place it was it was a correct quotation
so let's take a look he's telling me
that I'm misusing a logical necessity it
will make sense okay so here's the
question that demonstrates that we're
not talking about the same thing here if
P entails Q go he is necessary yes is Q
necessary no it's not no I mean this
this appears not just to be as kind of
having a different definition but
Mohammed his you're not understanding
what necessity means okay let's just
think about this question that I just
asked I said if P entails Q and P is
necessary is Q also necessary in other
words if P necessarily exists if it has
to happen right if there's no way that
it could not happen this is the fallacy
of equivocation yeah because you're
saying necessarily exists and my
definition of necessity throughout the
debate was not necessarily exists is
that it is the necessary existence so
you know it's a salt difference yeah so
necessarily exists no this thing is the
necessary existence the problem with
saying using the language of
propositional logic and statement logic
yeah a P equals Q is that it's not
actually befitting language and I'll
tell you why because P is differentiated
from Q so from what I'm understanding
from what you're saying here when you
said that this is what I understood
you're saying that you're saying
basically yeah that if P is the
necessary existence that entails Q which
is another necessary existence so you
you see the idea here but then that will
be T in propositional in statement logic
that
tautology so this is this is what you're
saying doesn't actually make any sense
at all
and if P then Q if that statement is
true if P's existence entails Q's
existence is Q also necessary right and
muhammad hijab says no he says that
somehow you can have a thing that is
necessarily true that has to be true
that makes something else true and yet
the second thing could be false he says
something is necessarily true and it
makes something else true and that thing
is the silly force so get me the
quotation where I said that because I
can't remember saying that in the debate
I come and we're publishing that in any
of my books and I can't remember saying
that at all so you see you're crying
about misrepresentation and you're
basically saying things I never sent you
said I said and then you said oh you
said something completely ha company
something I've never you will never find
it on the public record
yeah right you want to talk about
logical contradictions Muhammad hijab
this is one of the most basic that there
is to say that something is necessarily
true is to say that it is true in all
conditions under all interpretations in
a truth table
logically speaking to say that it cannot
be false in other words so consider this
question right P entails Q and P is
necessarily true that means that you're
able to say that it's true that P and
it's true when I use the word necessary
when he's using the word necessary I'm
talking about than necessary being he's
saying if P tells Q yeah and this is in
the bio in say my law schools quote
material implication yeah some
differentiate between implication
atonement some magicians differentiate
between implication and entailment
truth tables man if then what if then if
X then Y or sorry if P then Q play
equivocation is creative equivocation
you're using the word necessary yeah in
a way that has not been used for the
debate has not been used and then you
define it somewhere in your video as a
causal chain or something like that well
who defines it like that or would you
respect get me a paper of someone refer
to the clients necessity as a call
we'll chain who who defines it like that
you've you've made up your own
definition of necessity
yeah and then you equivocate it into the
discourse I made it very clear and
necessary existence is an uncaused a
thing that could not be any other way
that's how all of the philosophers of
religion all of the logicians have
defined it yeah I think that could not
be any other way
yeah it could mean and you're
equivocating it to me in the modal sense
uh it follows from basically so it
necessarily follows from but no one's
using in that sense bro so yeah you're
definitely equivocating and you're
trying to create something from nothing
and let's say let's say for the sake of
argument let's say it was a
contradiction ii do it to myself yeah
see if a sake of argument no problem how
does that affect my argument
how does PQ how does that affect my
argument affect my argument you're going
you're clutching at straws that you
can't number one you can't refute the
argument and number two you can't admit
defeat on these matters all right so
let's go for this prepare yourselves
it's another quote
okay so we've already dealt with your
previous one and we showed you how you
actually did say what you said you
didn't say yeah he agrees with me the
radio guy that was speaking to him that
the universe is a necessary existence
okay so I'm saying that you agree with
the radio man that the universe is a is
a necessary existence I think you the
audience should know by now what's going
on here I actually only just noticed
you've been disapproved once already you
know clear that you're just you're not
even meticulous enough to know your own
quotations and your there that's what
happens when young boys go into a
youtuber would you respect and I'm not
saying that to try and demean you I
think you're a very intelligent man as
well yeah but when you're a young boy
coming out at like 18 or 17 or something
like that and you're making mistakes and
you and you can't even man up and say
okay well actually I can't even defend
this position anymore then you're gonna
make mistakes like this stop being smug
yeah
and thought acting right this big you
can actually see me smirking smiling as
he's saying this like watch this clip
existence you can see the face of the
realization in a man this someone has
completely misunderstood what he's
saying it's it's kind of a second hand
embarrassment that you're seeing on my
face there you can see in my face that
I'm not just doing this after the fact
I'm not just going back and saying no no
no this is what I meant this is what I'm
saying I knew at the time that Muhammad
his job was misquoting me Muhammad his
job quoted me at minute 48 of my debate
with Cameron Batusi on the unbelievable
show so let's go find the quote ok
minute 48 let's sir let's watch this
together I'm just gonna say yeah I'm at
the University I couldn't be can be that
do you see how that objection kind of
riddles itself into the very first
premise because if I'm going to deny the
existence of contingent objects as
Cameron has defined them then that kind
of means that the universe and
everything in it is necessary in a sense
my 1 if you're gonna say I've got a
special thing God that doesn't require a
cause for its x-men exploration for its
existence and so on well I'm just gonna
say yeah the universe yeah can be can be
that do you see how that objection kind
of riddles itself into the very first
premise because if I'm going to deny the
existence of contingent objects as
Cameron has defined them then that kind
of means that the universe and
everything in it is necessary in a sense
and that would be enough because if the
whole reason that you need this
necessary being that you're calling God
to explain the universe is because
everything in the universe is contingent
then or at least some things in the
universe of contingent then if the the
premise the first premise is false and
there aren't in fact contingent things
in the universe then that means the
universe itself is necessary and
therefore there's no need for this extra
explanation so I think I do agree with
that objection that I think it arises at
the very beginning of the argument right
wait wait you saying please be very
attentive here
he's saying he does agree with it he's
saying I do agree with that objection
ie the Russell Ian objection Bertrand
Russell's objection which is that the
universe just is the universe is itself
the what do you call it the necessary
existence is necessary existence meaning
and necessary of necessary fact is a
fact that cannot be any other way
two plus two equals four that's
eternally going to be the case so a
necessary existence is eternal it cannot
be any other way so wait a minute if the
universe is eternal how could it come
from nothing contradiction okay we're
gonna have to break a sound and get a
bit philosophical kind of I suppose
right now with okay let's do that but
before you do that well how is that a
misquotation bro because you've accused
me of misquoting you you said here
misquotes me again all I said was that
you said that the universe does is is is
a necessary existence now the thing is
you're accusing me of misquoting you
yeah you're accusing me of miss calling
you and what I've shown here is in fact
all of my quotations have been correct
but from what I remember their follow
face or children he's cool this is my
Instagram and so I look like when I was
your age bro can you see that see that
big muscles there you see them just that
yeah I was about what 15 years old and
I'm only joking man yeah this is me and
you and then the debate bro that's you
and that's me the line in the back I'm
only joking
all right so and this is the this is
what you're gonna be insha'Allah you
know supporting soon and you're gonna be
on the podium like that doing dowels
brother if you're if you're a feel good
boy inshallah and if things don't get
out of hand that we don't Sophia okay
just looking at my my Instagram is is a
bit funny
okay so mmm
you don't want to be like this man trust
me now that what I'm trying to what I'm
trying to find is okay okay it's because
I put this here I put this here yeah
went to buy this book is good one yeah
Mohammad Othman book very good yes here
he was like soup so you've got two
choices you you either have to you have
to retract what you you wanna have to
bring yeah you know how to like accept
Islam or face public humiliation and I
was like
which completely negates racism look at
chapter 49 verse legend of the Quran
look at the Prophet said there's no
virtue of a black man or a white man
album now he's got three options option
1 to retract the statement option 2 yes
option 2 to provide the evidence face
public immunization today and there's no
sports option so don't so I didn't say
you bro you said I have two options one
of them was to accept Islam or to face
public humiliation and what we saw there
you know what I mean
is that that's not true but I don't have
not said that you've got two options one
of them is to accept Islam or the other
one is to face public humiliation so
thus this is basically on my phone just
so you know what I mean
if you wanna kind of like see oh I do
and yeah so yeah I mean so listen Alex
so nice try
I understand how you feel it's been a
year and you've been kind of probably
bombarded with all kinds of people
coming to you and saying to you that
that you didn't do - or not they take a
lot debate and whatever look I'm not
trying to forget it mandatory you know
you made your mistakes you learn for
next time but let's be sincere and you
know what I mean bro let's be sincere
it's been 22 minutes I don't know if
there's anything else there's a let's
see if this is anything else that that
you said although I need to count on top
yeah see what your main points were all
right so you said improper crediting the
first thing to note is that Mohammed hit
jobs version of this video is titled
Islam versus atheism Oxford University
debate this debate was not hosted by
Oxford University as it says in the
event description this was hosted by the
Oxford forum which is a student-run
society you can't have a student unless
is [__] fair enough
but I take your point I did actually
change that so I've got now Oxford forum
what else you got approval I know the
organizers of the debate they they put
in a lot of effort to try and get this
to
come to pass and when they did they got
absolutely no credit for it and okay
fair enough you know I apologize for not
advertising for the ad for those guys
and if they asked me to I would have by
the way I didn't Patrick did not ask me
if they would have I would have and I
think I did
to some extent my mentioning works for
forum but maybe you're right I could
have done a better job doing that I
don't think that's anything substantial
substantial your microphone cutting out
my microphone car as well my friend you
know I was not in control of the
microphones misquoted me so we done the
miss quotations yes is there any other
proven wrong by audience member yeah I
remember this I by the way I this was on
a on the issue of then this the the the
title of John John so internal just to
Mills book and you were right you were
right and I was wrong on that and I've
already I think I admitted that on the
actual yes I've written you a nice thing
yeah I've written you a nice thing here
so edited footage when when I was
reading the Koran they were disturbing
me and for us as Muslims you can't you
know be something reading over the Quran
so I found that disrespectful because in
the beginning we said conclusions five
minutes and I was gonna recite Quran and
and the guy was disturbing me within my
Quranic recitation so I just recorded
the Arabic again so that's not there's
nothing there controlling comments yeah
this is a big thing actually so I should
so I've written here in my comment Ebro
I written this video was hold comes for
review and the admins that have control
of my channel allowed the comments they
wanted to and didn't approve insulting
comments which insulted Islam the
religion of Islam etc so I'm not yeah I
don't have a agreement with you that I'm
gonna have all the comments going and as
you know YouTube allows us to delete
comments as well that's the advantage of
being an admin isn't it of having your
own channel so I don't know what the
issue is here if I had an agreement with
you cuz Islamic Lee I'm having a gray
with you then yeah I get it I you know
if I went against the agreement but I
don't have an agreement of you that just
let all the insulting comments and all
these things so I don't see what the
issue is here bro you know if you made
that agreement with me beforehand that
oh let all the comments go through and I
agreed with that and I went against that
agreement then I would say that's
morally questionable from my standpoint
but I didn't have such an agreement with
you so I don't see that as morally
questionable you say he misuses logical
necessity so I don't know what you mean
here should she would see what he's
saying it's only two minutes okay but
let me ask you questions much later but
it will make sense okay so here's the
question that demonstrates that we're
not talking about the same thing here if
P entails Q B is necessary yes is Q
necessary no it's not no I mean this
this appears not just to be us kind of
having a different this is not really
anything worthy of reply at this point
in time because I want to keep this all
separate from each other they see the
misquote matter
mere 48 he says this listen to this huh
prepare yourselves it's another quote he
agrees with the the radio guy that was
speaking to it okay so really and truly
what's the problem this one here I'll
accept an apology from you so the next
part of the discussion that we have is
kind of about morality and Abdullah
makes the point yeah okay well that was
the debate I don't know why you're doing
this one year later I really don't
understand proven wrong by audience
member okay I get proven wrong by what
kind of family members on a daily basis
but trust me I know you might think that
I don't get proven wrong like that
because of your experience with me but
trust me
that's ridiculous okay so look I don't
want this video to go on forever I
actually have no idea how long this
video is gonna be until I cut it down
because I've kind of been sat here just
picking out bits from the debate but
this should give you an idea of why I'm
just totally fed up totally fed up of
hearing about this debate you want to
know one of the worst parts is that
Muhammad hijab is uploaded this to his
channel it's got 700,000 views and they
won't let me upload the video to my
channel info why would you why would you
even request that or would you respect
like you know the cameraman had to be
paid
you know the microphone guys and there
were two cameramen so what-what were you
want you want to freeload I'm not being
funny but don't be entitled like you
know if you had you know one was
stopping you from bringing your own
cameraman or from getting one of your
friends to even record it on their phone
or something
and then why you acting like a young guy
like unorganized school boy come on look
at you man you're actually like
seriously - come on man you so you want
us to pay for your channel to grow when
your channel is attacking Islam it's a
bit crazy isn't it this is the this is
the road ruin other world him and like
he's controlling the comments so I'm the
I'm the admin of the of the YouTube
channel so what's your problem I mean I
don't know what's your issue here okay
you know half of Muslim YouTube on my
ass saying you got owned
you got read and the worst part isn't so
so you think that being a debater
is all about people in your echo chamber
telling you how good you are
bro it's fine we can have we can have
our echo chambers when it comes to the
bass you're gonna get that like you know
especially if you've got another person
with a bigger platform than you or the
same size platform or a smaller platform
but it's still quite big so you can
that's just something they then come to
me and say why isn't the video on your
channel schedule scared to upload is
because brother Mohammed his job smashed
you in the debate no job from why I run
by largely Department openness
statements this was the decision that
was made than I passed it on so what's
the problem they won't let me upload the
footage believe me I have asked I've
been on Twitter asking Muhammad his job
and I era to grant me permission to
upload the debate now by the time this
video goes out maybe they will have done
they've been ignoring me so far but if
they haven't if they haven't granted
that permission then I implore you to
ask them for permission right I'll leave
a link in the description to I errors
website where you can go to the contact
page and just ask them like I'm not
asking you to spam them it don't go do
that kind of thing I just know this guy
this young man here look would respect
yeah I don't know what you're trying to
achieve I genuinely don't know what
you're trying to achieve let's go to
your channel cuz last last thing I did
review was I put up a video look who
you're hanging around look at this
Islamic or behind and run with ya
anyway I went to your channel and you
wrote this Muhammad hijab has responded
to my latest video by accusing me of
being a racist I'm honestly not sure
this man is capable of productive
discussion now I've put this al-abadi
come what I've gotta lie you up for this
video
as you can see on private or something I
never once accused you of being a racist
bro and that's another misrepresentation
I asked some Mali women I'm not gonna go
into the video because you said some
things maybe it was a slip of the tongue
maybe whoever it was yeah I asked
certain women I made I put a pole there
yeah to see whoever
people Somali women thought what you
said was racist a lot of them said yes
you know I'm trying to say a lot I'm
like look if I come on my own
and I got my own community page have I
got my community page your channel yeah
community so look if I go on my
community page and go here sorry
you'll see that some some people found
it look as a Somali woman she found what
you said to be racist do you know I mean
so this what what is it because we we're
allowed to have these opinions now as I
said she before bro I'm giving you a
chance to kind of retract what you said
with the Somali women in the Muslim
woman and stop using derogatory and
loaded language of us and stop trying it
and so our prophet and stuff and then we
can have a healthy relationship if you
stop insulting because you need to
understand the red lines the red lines
for us is when you attack the Muslim
women when you're attack wasn't men with
Muslim people when you use loaded
language in sorting language you can
legally do it I'm not even arguing that
you know on a freedom of speech level
you shouldn't or couldn't
however that's your thing you can do it
but you're gonna get people not liking
you from our community so that's the red
lines and obviously our prophet is a red
line as well because for us we love our
prophet
we love muhammad sallallahoalyhiwasallam
we love allah we love we love them more
than we love ourselves and also it's
very difficult for you to grasp that
when you attack and I'm not even gonna
go to what you said but when you attack
our prophet even by using words which
are questionable what you're doing bro
is you're burning bridges yeah so
there's lots of people by law I can I
can attack the Sikh communities guru I
can I can attack I can say really
horrible things but you know I don't do
that you know I don't do that because I
want to maintain good relationship with
our communities and my advice to you as
someone a little bit older than you
understand and learn a little bit more
in life and have a bit more like a
little bit more life experience it's
brought on do this yeah because you're
an intelligent young man would you
respect
you have a bright future ahead of you
what you have to be you can't be
insulting people and communities and I
know you live in Oxford bro
and you know the county Cowley Street is
all Muslim Cowley Road area as all
Muslim areas some Muslim I'm also a
majority by some say so you don't want
to be you don't make enemies in your
area anyway so I wanted